hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i'm going to be
covering a very dense topic
basically i wanted to break down the
full timeline of events uh regarding
everything that has happened with
ign their support for palestine the
subsequent removal which is what you're
looking at right now this is an article
that is literally titled how to help
palestine but obviously it is now an
error for it for not found
they also had a tweet removed they
issued two statements
basically my intention here is to catch
everyone up to speed on everything that
has happened in part because i know not
everyone uses twitter which means you
can miss a lot of this news
in part to have it all in one place for
anyone who's trying to catch up and also
because i feel like i can offer a little
bit of
insight being an ex-ign employee to how
some of this may have gone down for the
initial context which i don't think you
should even get from me
there is currently ongoing conflict
between israel and palestine in which a
lot of palestinians have died or had
their houses destroyed some israelis
have also died but the casualties are
significantly higher on
the palestinian side it's largely
civilians and a lot of children
but i would definitely recommend you go
to any other source
than a video game writer on youtube if
you want to learn more about the actual
conflict i do not feel equipped
to appropriately explain that to anyone
so here is the original article that was
posted
i'm now looking at this on obviously
wayback waybackmachine or webarchive.org
it was originally called how to help
palestine if you scroll down there is a
donate link obviously this formatting is
going to be off because i'm using a
separate website and it's not actually
on ign anymore
but it basically said how to help
palestinian citizens by ign staff posted
on 14th of may and updated on the 15th
it says
palestinian civilians are currently
suffering in great numbers in jerusalem
gaza and west bank due to israeli forces
the ny times reported that most of the
deaths so far have occurred in gaza
we want to highlight the humanitarian
crisis in palestine because while there
has been fighting in the region for
decades
recent escalations have seen a
catastrophic loss of palestinian lives
below our charities and organizations on
the ground in those areas where you can
donate funds to help those most in need
we will continue to update this article
with other ways you can help
they go on to list a whole bunch of
sources i will link all of them in the
description below
they have the palestine's children
relief fund which has been providing
humanitarian assistance to injured and
sick children
anera which is a non-profit organization
that works on the ground with partners
in palestine specifically west bank and
gaza
offering resources for both emergency
relief and long-term needs in areas of
health education and economic
development
the united nations relief works agency
the medal aid for palestinians and
doctors without borders which is a
charity that i've raised money for a
number of times before because they are
fantastic
doctors without borders has medical
teams on the ground in jerusalem and has
been treating palestinians who've been
injured by israeli police
they also added uh basically for further
reading on the region check out this
timeline of the conflict
which links to an article from the
washington post about the
israelia-palestinian conflict
a chronology they also have a link to
why it seems to keep happening some
background on the current fighting
a feat of live updates and they go on to
say we hope you'll join us in helping
civilians in need in the middle east
regions by donating to the above
organizations and causes and i do feel
it's worth noting because this is a one
point of confusion that i've seen on the
internet
ign does not have any policy against
posting this kind of thing so i've seen
people say well it's a video game
website ign hasn't been a video game
website for quite a long time ign is an
entertainment website if anything they
also at this point do a significant
amount of fundraising i have helped them
with
a whole bunch of charity streams
recently this is not something that uh
their parent companies j2 global or zip
davis have ever taken any kind of stand
against
i feel like that's important to note um
just because some of the conversation
i've seen around this has basically said
well they should have expected this to
be taken down the parent company
doesn't uh own them so they can do that
that is technically not true there is no
internal
policy against publishing really
anything on the ign website
and uh none of their other fundraising
efforts have ever been removed so there
was no way for the staff to predict
necessarily that this particular thing
would be removed it is not against any
of their content
policy to post something like this um
the ign editorial staff did not break
any rules
uh as ign employees owned by zip davis
or j2 global by publishing
at least that was the best of my
understanding that was the case when i
worked there i never had any questioning
for any
of the charity things that i organized
while i did work at ign it never even
had to be taken to
zip davis or j2 global so alongside this
article there was a tweet
i'm sourcing jordanfish here jwordfish
on twitter
because i don't have a screenshot of the
tweet um which did say that this is from
the official ign account literally
twitter.com
ign palestinian civilians are currently
suffering in great numbers in jerusalem
gaza and the west bank here are some
great organizations you can donate to in
order to help those in need and it links
to the article and this did get a
tremendous
amount of engagement compared to your
average ign tweet it has 85 000 likes
3 984 quote tweets and 30 000 retweets
um which is just at the time of this
screenshot obviously
but if i go to ign's twitter feed from
before it was posted
we have a tweet with 1.4 thousand likes
795 likes 6 000 likes since a fair
amount
actually chris hemsworth news apparently
675 likes 932 likes 281 likes
you get the idea 85 000 is a lot for ign
so naturally
the news of this spread pretty quickly
they did also have this on the website
um this would have been on
every page i believe i'm sourcing axios
for this next to the ign logo was the
palestinian flag which was also of
course removed so the next thing that
happened uh this is also may 15th and
i'm sourcing andy robinson here who is a
news journalist uh he sourced
instagram i know they also posted it on
facebook but basically ign
israel posted dear readers we two were
amazed to discover this morning a
misleading and confusing donation
campaign found on the american website
ign
it is important for us to emphasize that
we condemn this action and did not take
part in it or were aware of it this is
not our way
we at ign israel support the state of
israel obviously and support idf
soldiers who do everything to keep us
all in these tough days we work in every
way possible to remove this misleading
and offensive content from the american
edition which does not represent our
views now something that is very
important to note about this
is that ign has um a lot of
international outlets the
only ones that function under the same
editorial voice that you would consider
to be
the main ign the first ign the original
ign
ign us uk australia and japan
they are all effectively one company who
make content that they publish on
ign.com all of the other companies that
you may have seen like ign brazil
ign israel they are basically
franchisees i definitely know from
working there that there is very little
communication between these companies
they don't talk they don't agree with
what's published
between each other but the franchised
websites do have access to
um and i guess permission to repost
things from the ign website some of them
will pull things directly
but there was an incident when i was
working there that i think it was maybe
ign russia
posted something that was in the ign
back end before it was supposed to be
posted which meant that it leaked but
they do have access
to the main ign but they are not the
main ign
so when they say that you know they
didn't know that this would happen
they didn't take part in it they weren't
aware of it that is true because they
are effectively a separate company they
just use ign branding
this is why sometimes people get
confused when they see it on metacritic
for example
you can see a review from ign brazil for
a game that's a 7 out of 10 and a review
from ign america
or just ign blanket that's an 8 out of
10 for the same game
it's because they are effectively
completely different websites just using
the same name
based on the region ign israel whoever
owns this website
is effectively paying for the name ign
to give themselves some more legitimacy
potentially some more eyes
more credibility but they are not really
the same company unless things have
changed there was one person
i know who was working to basically make
sure that they maintained relationships
with all of the different
uh ign branches but that person while i
worked there
did not work at the ign us office and it
was really about just talking to those
different companies it was never about
going to them and then bringing
something back to the us team or
anything like that so they are
very separate there is no reality where
the ign us team would ever have to
consider the israel team because they
may as well not even know that they
exist
ignus is ign.com they publish things to
go on ign.com they don't publish things
to go on ign israel but ign israel is
able to pull that in if they want
of course there's some cross
accountability i'm sure the contracts
are pretty interesting
but for the most part it is just ign
israel
paying ign to let them use that name i
hope that all makes sense so a number of
hours after this post went up
the ign tweet was deleted and of course
the article was deleted
now this is a part of this video that is
conjecture i don't think these two
things are related i've seen a lot of
this conversation happening on twitter
having worked there and knowing how
these kinds of things work i do not
believe that ign israel holds enough
power
that j2 global or zif davis again ign's
parent companies
pulled these things down just because of
ign israel i really don't believe that's
the case
i've seen tweets saying oig and israel
must be paying them a lot for them to
pull this down
while i'm sure there was probably an
uncomfortable conversation to be had and
an email sent there
i do not believe that the us side
zip davis or j2 removed any of this
content just because ign israel
reached out to them they do not have
that kind of power they are a franchisee
who is benefiting themselves from using
the ign name they don't get to control
what ign as a brand does
i very strongly believe that this
happened because someone who is high up
at zif davis or j2 supports israel or
they are worried about business partners
supporting israel
which should be big business partners
not the franchisees essentially
firmly believe that it was pulled down
because someone at j2 or zip davis
supports israel
and does not want any company underneath
them saying that they support
palestine and it does actually look like
ign israel actually removed the
the instagram post um so that's worth
noting it is also worth noting that the
same thing happened with game informer
game informal also shared an article in
support of palestine
and this is what it looks like right now
this did originally say how to donate to
help palestine
so next in the timeline of events would
be um a number of ign employees tweeting
that they were disheartened disgusted
upset
uh by the posts being removed and that
it was not communicated with them
um that is something that i know from
these employees telling me that
personally that this just
happened they didn't know it was going
to happen they did not approve it
it happened so the next step is that
effectively in the middle of the night
it's going to say 4 20 p.m here because
i'm currently in australia
the ign official twitter account tweeted
across ign our hearts are heavy as we
follow the events in israel palestine
and across the region
our first thought is always for the
broader aegean community our employees
readers and partners and our hopes for
their safety and well-being
we have a track record of supporting
humanitarian efforts and charities
across the globe
in the instance of our recent post
regarding how to help civilians in the
israel-palestinian conflict our
philanthropic
instincts to help those in need was not
in line with our intent of trying to
show support for all people impacted by
tragic events by highlighting only one
population the post mistakenly left the
impression that we were politically
aligned with one side
that was not our intention and we
sincerely regret the error we do intend
to continue to use our platforms and
resources to aid those civilian lives
impacted across the entire area
as part of this effort we have made a
donation of 25 000
to save the children an organization
that works to support children
everywhere and provides emergency aid in
natural disasters war and
other conflicts thank you for your
support and for always engaging with us
our community is a huge part of what
makes ign special
we will continue to follow global events
and look for ways to lend our support in
productive helpful ways
so once again um and this is something
that i did speak about on twitter and
that i know to be true
this was not the ign employees uh the
ign employees
that you know the editors the the
artists the engineers the people who
work in the los angeles or
uh san francisco offices where for
context i believe most of
davis and j2 are actually in new york i
met
maybe two of those people in the entire
time that i worked at ign they generally
were just
very very very separate and had nothing
to do with anything that we did other
than not giving people raises
but for the editorial team for a writer
who worked at ign very separate to
everything
i ever did the tweet and the article
were not taken down by ign employees
i'm sure an ign employee did have to
actually go into the back end of ign and
hit delete
but that was absolutely on order from
someone at zif davis or j2 global
the same thing applies to this tweet zip
davis and j2 global don't have access to
the ign twitter i don't imagine i don't
think the social
team has shared the login for the ign
twitter with zip davis that would be a
very strange thing to do especially
again considering these companies do
from an editorial standpoint operate
very separately but this was forced
this was not something the ign staff
wrote the people
who you interact with on twitter who
write the articles who are the faces of
videos
they did not write this i imagine again
conjecture that upper management and ign
probably did have to work with j2 global
and zip davis on putting this together
but the ign staffers were not the ones
who wrote this and were not the ones who
removed either of the tweets
or at the very least it was not by their
choice this was absolutely a forced
thing that you should not assume anyone
who works at ign is actually doing the
grunt work of working at ign
agreed with this in any capacity so the
follow-up to this came this morning
uh this is a letter that's on
ignores.medium.com it says an open
letter to leadership at ign's
davis and j2 global which i feel does
implicate
leadership at ign that does mean that
upper management had to have a hand in
this i just don't think that upper
management went to zip davis
if davis and j2 came to them complained
and then they had to figure it out that
is their jobs
but essentially it was published two
hours ago at this point and
is written by employees of ign it says
we do not represent the entirety of
ign's workforce but a collective of
staff members from multiple departments
and international offices
the letter says to the management of j2
global and zif davis and the corporate
leadership of ign
we the undersigned employees of ign are
appalled by the recent management
decision to subvert our editorial
autonomy and remove our post-directing
aid to the palestinian civilians
currently suffering a humanitarian
crisis in gaza the west bank and
jerusalem it goes on to say in our
original post we offered our readers
ways to support charities that help
injured and sick children supply
educational resources and food
assistance to victims and provide
emergency medical relief to those
wounded or displaced by the conflict
we feel these efforts should not be
controversial all humans deserve access
to these basic rights and it is
important for those with means to offer
aid in times of humanitarian crisis
our original post was shared by
thousands of people and because of
aign's size and reach we were able to
serve as a leader for much of the rest
of the industry
to also help support those whose lives
are torn apart by this conflict we were
proud to be a part of a team at a site
that was able and willing to offer this
level of visibility to such critical
humanitarian support efforts
the decision to take down the post was
made a day and a half after it was
published the takedown took place in the
early hours of the morning on a weekend
with no communication to its initial
authors
the general ign staff or the public as
to why it happened
again i believe that that means
management are the ones who took this
down
ign's editorial team has guidelines
about updating content deemed needful of
changes something that we've done
multiple times in the past but wholesale
removal of pieces without posting an
explanatory statement is expressly
against our usual policy which i think
is a very important note
promoting charity is not actually
against ign's policy in any way under j2
or zip davis
but removing posts without explaining
why actually is
it goes on to say finally more than 12
hours after the issue was first flagged
to the broader team in our internal
slack our staff received a late night
email from ign leadership
while after reasonable working hours for
the ign global team with the same
statement that was to be published
publicly on the ign twitter account an
hour later
there was no indication in the initial
email that it would also serve as our
official statement on the matter while
we are glad to see a sizeable donation
being made to save the children we feel
the decision to remove the original
article on social post as well as a
subsequent statement from management
is not only actively harmful to ign's
public reputation and its employees
which i do think is a pretty significant
part of this it's the front-facing
people at ign who'll get
held accountable for this not the people
making
the millions of dollars who work at j2
global in zip davis who actually did all
of this
in any case but also highly
disrespectful to much of its content
team and broader staff this statement
inaccurately ascribes to attraction to
those across
ign rather than to the members of our
upper management team who made the
decision
giving a public impression that the
decision was made by the editorial staff
despite this being a choice we did not
make collectively and which many of us
do not agree with
following an ign wide meeting this
morning we have come to understand that
this was a clear instance of corporate
overreach and demonstrated blatant
disregard for the most basic standards
of journalistic integrity and editorial
independence
which i do think is very important
especially because they didn't remove it
again because they have some kind of
policy against charity it's clearly
because they don't agree with that
particular charity
and this is the only strong opinion that
i will give in this entire video which
is intended to be more informational
than anything else
i think freedom of press is extremely
important even if press makes tons of
mistakes and i think ign has made tons
of mistakes and they did when i watched
there and they have in subsequent years
but i think a parent company who owns
them
bought them a number of years ago trying
to all of a sudden step in and say you
can't say that or you can
say this when they've never done it
before that i'm aware of is very
concerning a disturbing precedent
and actually makes ign more of a
political mouthpiece
rather than them trying to remove
politics from the website it means that
ign
then becomes a political force for
whatever j2 ends if davis believe in
you don't want this you want the
individual writers at ign who will come
and go
to speak freely give their opinions
freely even if they aren't opinions that
you agree with that's all i'm going to
say from my own perspective here
freedom of press is very important even
if you don't agree with the press they
basically go on to say what i'm saying
here
the business interests of a
publication's ownership and its
editorial staff should say separate at
all times
so strongly agree they continue by
saying importantly we feel the latest
statement dangerously tones what was a
matter of supporting innocent civilians
facing a humanitarian crisis
into a harmful case of both sides-ism
helping children and civilians harmed by
the horrors of war should be
uncontroversial no matter who the two
sides are
and is in keeping with ign's ongoing
efforts to highlight causes that are
important to our team
such as our support for black lives
matter last year and our more recent
celebration of aapi heritage month and
joining the call to end aapi hate
the victims here deserve the same
support we recognize the concerns
expressed by our management but are
nonetheless gravely disappointed by the
lack of respect shown to our content
team and broader staff in this matter
and expect our leaders to take
responsibility for their decisions
we the undersigned are calling for an
all hands meeting that includes ign
upper management and anyone at j2 global
or zip davis who had a hand in the
decision by the end of the week
in which we would like a full
transparency about the reasoning and
process behind the post's removal
and i think that that's very fair we ask
that the management body responsible for
the decision accept their responsibility
publicly
we ask that management recognize ign's
editorial authority and autonomy with
regards to what it publishes regardless
of whether that work is news reviews
features guides video content or
promotion of initiatives our staff feels
are important such as issue awareness or
charitable support again something ign
has done a number of times without any
problem this is something that i have
worked on with ig and i can tell you
firsthand from
the charity work that ice beer had while
i worked there and since leaving there
i've effectively become a charity
consultant of sorts for agn
this is not something that has ever come
up until now this is not a blanket rule
against politics this is not
a blanket rule against humanitarian aid
it is a blanket rule against supporting
palestine
while we want to make sure all voices on
our team ign management included feel
able to weigh in on what we say as a
site and how we say it
we are adamant that corporate leadership
does not get the final word in editorial
decisions finally we ask the management
work with our staff to republish the
piece
we are open to doing this through a
process that incorporates management
feedback and concerns about how its
content is perceived but we firmly
believe that we must be allowed to
advocate for humanitarian causes freely
across all our channels we are a team of
creators who love what we do and take
pride in our work which has previously
enjoyed the support of and freedom of
unnecessary interference from
our parent companies again in my
experience working in ign that is true i
never felt like
j2 or zf davis interfered with really
anything i only ever thought of them as
the people who were the reason that me
and my friends were all underpaid
but i never saw them step in in any way
other than i think i occasionally got a
few emails
um from someone who worked at zip davis
being like hey alana this is a great
article
that's really the extent of it they did
not have any kind of editorial power
they said we would like that
relationship to continue to be a
positive one is it
it is our hope that management
recognizes its errors this past weekend
and is willing to work with us to ensure
that ign can continue to stand as a
trusted publication
unconstrained by interference from
corporate interests and able to freely
inform its audience about opportunities
to support important and meaningful
causes around the world
sincerely and then these other people
who are undersigned
i think probably the most notable
absences from the list just to name the
ones that are obvious to me are damon
hatfield and brandon tyrell
you'll know damon from his time hosting
the fix and ign news and brandon tyrell
from ign unlocked that's not any attempt
to throw shade at those people just
something that i'm like those are
probably the two names that i'm missing
that people
will know of the best i think i have no
idea why they're missing cannot make any
comment on that
i actually just finished editing this
video and then this update arrived
um so we now have a statement from ign
israel as well which was just issued
at around 8 30 p.m pacific time it says
a statement from ign israel ign israel
would like to clarify its remarks in
relation to a social media post we made
regarding the ign u.s fundraiser article
posted last friday night
saturday morning which was subsequently
removed by ign u.s
we choose to believe ign us's motivation
for the original fundraiser article was
purely humanitarian not political
and that it did not intend to take a
side of the people civilians
of either population however the
prominent image of the palestinian flag
in
ign us's header during a time of active
conflict between two states
which severely affects the innocent
civilians of both populations strongly
gave this appearance in our view
many of the ig and israel team are
currently sheltering during heavy rocket
attacks and we felt that we
the people of israel have been thrown
under the bus by the brand that we love
and have worked closely together with
for the past seven years ign
our community felt the same way at the
time of huge distress which is why we
released an initial statement before we
could connect with ignus about their
post
due to the weekend at different time
zones in addition to the impression of
one side and is created by the flag
which was subsequently changed to the
international red cross by ign us
which we felt was a reasonable change
the article itself made no reference to
the fact that on both sides of the
conflict there is a loss of life and
destruction which is tragic no matter
where or why it occurs iogen israel did
not intend to and would never condemn
any genuine charitable effort or
fundraising in and of itself rather we
took issue with the fact that it
appeared that ign was taking aside
regarding the conflict as described
above
we also want to clarify that the
intended meaning elsewhere in our
original post that ign us original
article did not speak for
all other editions not any other
editions in other words
ig and us's original article did not
represent ign israel on this topic which
of course we stand by in relation to the
original concerns as clarified above
but also we do not speak for other
editions either furthermore while we
obviously made our concerns clearly
known to ign us which raised alarm on
their side neither a ign's initial
change from the palestine flag to the
international red cross null b
the subsequent removal of its original
article entirely nor c
the statement it released on sunday
evening pacific time were ultimately due
to actions taken by ig and israel
these decisions were made these
decisions were made solely in the us
if i jin releases a new neutral
fundraiser in relation to this awful
conflict
we would love to support it so that is
basically what i'm saying is that i
don't believe any of this happened
because of ign israel i do also want to
say though and you know this is
an opinion again conjecture what i think
happened here is that ig and israel
actually got in a lot of trouble
for posting out against ign that
probably did breach their contract but
yes there is no world in which this
uh you know with the mentions of the a b
and c down here wasn't
also um written with lawyers in mind
that the people of z davis and j2 didn't
have
any say in this basically it means to me
that ig and israel got in a lot of
trouble
and were forced to issue this statement
whether they agree with it or not
i would guess that it was a result of a
fair amount of back and forth and this
is what they mutually agreed upon that
is essentially the timeline of events
for this
uh a lot of ign employees i have seen
tweeting um clarifying
what editorial staff means i think
they're probably a little bit more
concerned about this than the general
public is but it basically means that
uh names on this list also include
people who work in engineering people
who work in design not necessarily just
the writers
aside from that i know that they are
still working i don't know what
um threat is involved here i know this
letter took them a very long time to
write i'm not sure how many people were
involved
in writing it though and i do know that
a tremendous amount of ign employees
have been tweeting this from
their personal accounts basically just
to um submit that statement where they
are unable to
on the official ign account so that is
the timeline of events
and all of the facts essentially the one
other thing that i wanted to address
just because i saw a few questions about
it again
uh people asking uh how strict ign has
been about things that are posted in the
past
in my experience um especially from
personal accounts people could post
really whatever they wanted when i
worked there and this policy has changed
i was not allowed to talk about video
games on youtube
um they basically had right over
anything i had to say about video games
and i was not allowed to stream on
twitch unless i streamed from an account
that ign owned
ign would get the money from which meant
that i opted not to do it because if i
would have built a twitch following
the minute that i left the company ign
would get that entire following so the
whole time that i was there anyone would
ever ask me why don't i twitch stream
the answer was that ign's policy made it
very unappealing those rules have
changed there is a lot more freedom now
a lot of ign employees do stream
but generally uh in my experience
working there even under
upper management i felt that they were
very supportive of any opinions that i
had they were very supportive of me
tweeting or using instagram
to voice any of those opinions they were
wonderful about any of the charity uh
things that i
organized while i was at ign or anything
that i did separately um
and a lot better than some of the other
companies that i worked for this is an
unusual circumstance and i think that's
why it's getting so much coverage
i would say that zip davis and j2 global
were very hands-off with the editorial
team in a way that was actually
very good for a writer working there and
again
i felt like leadership was very
supportive of their
writers their staff in general their
editorial team having opinions
or advocating for things on their own
without any
um interference but i hope that explains
the whole situation
and adds a little bit of pockets of
information that i have that you may not
just see on your twitter timeline
and if anything new happens i will
probably try to update this in a pinned
comment
uh because my intent here really is to
just keep people up to date on
everything that's happened to you but
that is it for me today everyone i will
see you guys next time bye